الحرب مستمرة
وسط هدوء ظاهري لمفاوضات مؤقتة،
لكن هل توقفت العمليات
خلال هذه المفاوضات؟
.روسيا تدمر أكبر طائرة شحن في العالم
، وحضر جوي تتسع رقعته في الخارطة
الأوربية مع ارتفاع في تكاليف الرحلات الجوية أيضا...
وهل تتجه الدول لإطالة الحرب
عقب بطء الهجمات مقارنة ببداية الحرب؟
مرحلة إعادة ترتيب الأواراق،
والرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي على الشاشة
كما هي العادة منذ بداية المعارك....
هل سمح الفيفا للبطولات العالمية
بمطالبة روسيا بإيقاف الحرب على أوكرانيا؟
ولماذا كان يفرض عقوبات على اللاعبين العرب
والمسلمين في حال مطالبة إسرائيل
بوقف حربها على الفلسطينيين؟
لماذا هذه الازدواجية في المعايير
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالغربيين؟
ولماذا يتهم العالم الدول الأوروبية بالعنصرية؟
تجري المفاوضات الروسية الأوكرانية
على الحدود بين بيلاروسيا وأوكرانيا،
لكن الهجمات العسكرية مستمرة داخل المدن،
وكأن المفاوضات غير موجودة،،،
فبوتين الذي أعلن توقف العمليات
أثناء المفاوضات الأولى ها هو يدخل هذه المرة
في المفاوضات لكن دون إيقاف المعارك
كما هي طريقة الروس المعتادة،،،
وخلال ذلك بثت وزارة الدفاع الروسية  صورا قالت أنها لطائرات أوكرانية من طراز ميغ92 مدمرة في مطار مدينة إيفانو...
..
وفي تصريحها قالت شركة الصناعات الدفاعية الأوكرانية أن القصف الروسي تسبب في تدمير واحتراق أكبر طائرة شحن في العالم  وهي أوكرانية الصنع من طراز أنتونوف ٢٢٥، في قصف روسي على مطار غوستوميل القريب من كييف،، وأضافت الشركة أن ترميم هذه الطائرة سيكلف ما يزيد عن ٣مليارات دولار وسيستغرق وقتا طويلا..
...
بينما كانت وسائل إعلام أوكرانية قالت إن الجيش الأوكراني قد رد بإسقاط مروحيتين روسيتين شمالي كييف..
لكن لماذا قلت حدة العمليات؟
بداية سريعة وقوية للحرب.. لكن عملياتها الآن تتسم بالبطء .....ففي البداية الحرب لم تكن مفاجئة وتم التخطيط لها لعدة أشهر ما ترك الأطراف تحضر لها بشكل أو بآخر وهو ما فعله الغرب وأمريكا مع أوكرانيا.  فاستعد زيلينسكي والغرب للمفاجآت التي قد يواجهونها من بوتين لكن هل تكفي التحضيرات لإيقاف الدب الروسي؟، ..
..
(مرحلة جديدة)
مرحلة إعادة التخطيط الاستراتيجي.. فبوتين يفاوض من جانب ويستعد بخطط جديدة من جانب آخر،
قدم بوتين في التفاوض والقدم الأخرى موجودة على الأرض... والتخطيط لاستخدام السلاح النووي الذي تم تجهيزه وهو في مرحلة الاستعداد بانتظار أوامر القصف، ،، كما يجري تجهيز القنبلة الفراغية تحسبا لحرب المدن.. بوتين يرى قضية أوكرانيا هي مسألة حياة أو موت بالنسبة للروس لكن الأمريكان والغرب لا يبدو أنها كذلك بالنسبة لهم..
...
(زيلينسكي معتاد على الوقوف أمام الكاميرا)
الرئيس الأوكراني أو الفنان التلفزيوني الأوكراني يبدو أنه لم يعتد الابتعاد عن الأضواء، وخرج مجددا في كلمة متلفزة
وقال : "نطالب الاتحاد الأوروبي بضم أوكرانيا على الفور باستخدام آلية جديدة".
وتابع زيلينسكي قائلا: "نحن ممتنون لشركائنا على وقوفهم معنا، لكن هدفنا أن نكون مع الأوروبيين كافة وأن نتساوى معهم، أنا متأكد أننا نستحق ذلك، ومتأكد أن الأمر ممكن".
وخلال ذلك بثت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
صورا قالت أنها لطائرات أوكرانية
من طراز ميغ92 مدمرة في مطار مدينة إيفانو...
وفي تصريحها قالت شركة الصناعات الدفاعية
الأوكرانية أن القصف الروسي تسبب في تدمير
واحتراق أكبر طائرة شحن في العالم
وهي أوكرانية الصنع من طراز
أنتونوف ٢٢٥، في قصف روسي على مطار
غوستوميل القريب من كييف،،
وأضافت الشركة أن ترميم هذه الطائرة
سيكلف ما يزيد عن ٣مليارات دولار
وسيستغرق وقتا طويلا..
بينما كانت وسائل إعلام أوكرانية قالت
إن الجيش الأوكراني قد رد بإسقاط مروحيتين
روسيتين شمالي كييف..
لكن لماذا قلت حدة العمليات؟
بداية سريعة وقوية للحرب..
لكن عملياتها الآن تتسم بالبطء ....
.ففي البداية الحرب لم تكن مفاجئة
وتم التخطيط لها لعدة أشهر ما ترك الأطراف
تحضر لها بشكل أو بآخر وهو ما فعله الغرب
وأمريكا مع أوكرانيا.  فاستعد زيلينسكي والغرب
للمفاجآت التي قد يواجهونها من بوتين
لكن هل تكفي التحضيرات لإيقاف الدب الروسي؟، ..
(مرحلة جديدة)
مرحلة إعادة التخطيط الاستراتيجي..
فبوتين يفاوض من جانب ويستعد بخطط جديدة
من جانب آخر،
قدم بوتين في التفاوض والقدم الأخرى
موجودة على الأرض... والتخطيط لاستخدام
السلاح النووي الذي تم تجهيزه وهو في مرحلة
الاستعداد بانتظار أوامر القصف، ،،
كما يجري تجهيز القنبلة الفراغية
تحسبا لحرب المدن..
بوتين يرى قضية أوكرانيا هي مسألة حياة أو موت
بالنسبة للروس لكن الأمريكان والغرب
لا يبدو أنها كذلك بالنسبة لهم..
(زيلينسكي معتاد على الوقوف أمام الكاميرا)
الرئيس الأوكراني أو الفنان التلفزيوني
الأوكراني يبدو أنه لم يعتد الابتعاد عن الأضواء،
وخرج مجددا في كلمة متلفزة
وقال : "نطالب الاتحاد الأوروبي بضم أوكرانيا
على الفور باستخدام آلية جديدة".
وتابع زيلينسكي قائلا:
"نحن ممتنون لشركائنا على وقوفهم معنا،
لكن هدفنا أن نكون مع الأوروبيين كافة وأن نتساوى
معهم، أنا متأكد أننا نستحق ذلك، ومتأكد أن الأمر ممكن".
وأعلن زيلينسكي أنه تحدث مع رؤساء
البرتغال وليتوانيا وفرنسا وبولندا
بالإضافة إلى رئيس وزراء
بلجيكا وإسبانيا والمملكة المتحدة
مؤكدا على أهمية الدعم
"غير المشروط وغير المسبوق"
الذي قدموه لأوكرانيا.
بينما أعلن زيلينسكي إن "16 طفلا قتلوا
و45 جرحوا في الأيام الأربعة الأولى للحرب".
كما أضاف   "روسيا تكبدت خسائر كبيرة
ولا نعلم الهدف من هذه الخسائر الروسية كلها"
وجدد تصريحه القائل بإن "4500 جندي روسي
قتلوا ولا تصدقوا المسؤولين في الجيش الروسي".
وقال أيضا: كل أوكراني يعتبر رئيسا للبلاد
في الوقت الحالي والكل مسؤول عن الدفاع
عنها وكل أوكراني هو جندي من مكانه
(الحظر يضر الجميع)
خلال كل هذه العمليات قررت كل من
فرنسا وإيطاليا وألمانيا والدنمارك وإيرلندا وبلجيكا
وهولندا والنرويج إغلاق مجالها الجوي
في وجه الطيران الروسي لتنضم
لكل من بريطانيا وبلغاريا وبولندا
وجمهورية التشيك ورومانيا ودول البلطيق الثلاث،
الذين كانوا قد أغلقوا مطاراتهم أمام الطيران الروسي،،
في المقابل حظرت روسيا الرحلات الجوية
من بلغاريا وجمهورية التشيك ودول البلطيق
وبولندا ورومانيا وسلوفينيا وبريطانيا،
ومع هذا الحظر الأوروبي أجبرت شركات الطيران
الروسية مثل إيرفلوت على التوجه جنوبا
نحو تركيا لأجل رحلاتها المتجهة غربا،
كما تواجه شركات الطيران الأوروبية
التي تتجه شرقا تكاليف أعلى أيضا،
مع حظر موسكو مجالها الجوي ردا على الحظر
الأوروبي المفروض عليها...
(الغرب العنصري)
شهدت الملاعب الدولية مطالبات متعددة لبوتين
لإيقاف الحرب على أوكرانيا رغم أن هذا الفعل
مخالف لقانون الفيفا الذي يحرم إقحام السياسة
في الرياضة بذريعة عدم إدخال مشاحنات
بين اللاعبين والفرق وقد تم فرض عقوبات
فيما سبق على اللاعب المسلم فريدريك كانوتيه
وأيضا اللاعب المصري الكبير محمد أبو تريكه
لوقوفهم إلى جانب القضية الفلسطينية
وتعاطفهم مع الضحايا الفلسطينيين.
اليوم نسي الفيفا والغرب تلك القوانين
وتذكروا إنسانيتهم فجأة وكل ذلك لأجل
عيون الأوكرانيين.
أما بالنسبة للإعلام السياسي فتابعوا معنا هذه المقاطع:
هنا في المقطع الأول:
مراسل قناة CBS News :
هذه ليست العراق ولا سوريا أو أفغانستان
هذا بلد متحضر  ودولة أوروبية ولا يصح
أن يحدث فيها مثل هذا
أما في المقطع الثاني: مراسل BBC:
استميحكم عذراً فما يحدث يثير المشاعر
لأني أشاهد أطفال أوروبيين عيونهم زرقاء وشعرهم
أشقر يُقتلون بصواريخ ومروحيات بوتين كل يوم،
لماذا يا هذا؟!!وهل الحرب مفروضة
على ذوي البشرة السمراء ومحرمة عليكم؟
وهنا مقطع ثالث لمراسلة NBC عن الأوكرانيين:
نحن لا نتحدث عن لاجئين سوريين
بل جيراننا الأوكرانيين. إنهم مسيحيون،
وبيض، وأناسٌ يشبهون البولنديين!
يالها من عنصرية مستفزة!!!
عنصرية مقيتة واستهزاء بأرواح المسلمين والعرب
وإنسانية زائفة طالما تغنى بها الغربيون والأوروبيون..
لكن مع كل هذا فالعرب والمسلمون لا يفكرون
كما يفكر الغرب ولا يريدون للحرب أن تستمر
فهل يعي الغرب ذلك ويدركون كل ما اقترفوه
في بلاد العرب والمسلمين؟